[Music]
mental health among children remains a
really big concern in our community
following a rise in suicides within the
clark county school district
during distance education some families
see the toll from isolation during the
pandemic
but as kristin drummond shows us others
don't notice a change in behavior
until it's too late they're not
statistics
they were children who had lives darlene
terry berry continues coping with the
loss of her granddaughter
angel a 17 year old clark county school
district student who died by
suicide in october she had hung herself
one of at least 20 ccsd students who
have taken their own lives
since the start of distance education in
march the ages range from elementary
school to high school but
the data shows most are teenagers now
this
whole pandemic has changed our lives so
drastically
that includes adjusting to distance
education a decision by the district to
try and prevent the spread of cobit 19
among staff and students on campuses
that choice though comes at a possible
cost to mental health
i understand the reasons for it i do
but it doesn't mean it's not affecting
these kids
how else do you explain
what's happening i didn't have the heart
to put it up and now i don't have the
heart to take it down
now darlene adjusts to her new normal
shrines around her home
and struggling to take down a christmas
tree because it reminds her of angel
she loved doing the ornaments and stuff
like that
living among memories while reflecting
on the past
kristen drummond 8 news now
darlene wants to share her story so
other families avoid the grief and the
pain that she's going through
so coming up tonight here at six her
warning and the possible signs and what
other families who lost a child by
suicide
tell kristen about the isolation during
distance education